what if I told you that this clean Call
of Duty footage was actually Roblox I'm
actually lost for words yes this shiny
streamlined looking shooter called front
lines is in fact a recreation of cod
made in Roblox this is Roblox understand
this is ridiculous and depending on who
you ask it's actually better than the
current Cod I don't know if it's just
like a meme or exaggerated hype or not
but everyone's saying it's better than
modern warfare 2. is a free to play
video game that literally plays and has
better movement than Call of Duty as you
can see how is Roblox doing Call of Duty
better than Call of Duty
played Roblox but I
but a ton of Modern Warfare when I was a
teenager and this absolutely looks like
the kind of thing that I'd want to
destroy 12 year olds in